วันนี้เราจะมาพูดถึงลูกบอลที่กำลังหมุน แต่จริงๆ แล้วมันไม่ใช่ลูกบอลและก็ไม่ได้หมุนด้วย ใน Qiskit in the
classroom เราจะพูดถึงคุณสมบัติควอนตัมที่เรียกว่าสปิน โดยดูจากการทดลองที่ค้นพบหลักฐานครั้งแรกของมัน
ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ Qiskit in the classroom ในซีรีส์นี้เราจะใช้ Qiskit สำรวจแนวคิดพื้นฐานที่มักจะ
ปรากฏในหลักสูตรที่เกี่ยวกับ Quantum Computing แต่ละวิดีโอจะมาพร้อมกับโมดูลเชิงโต้ตอบ
ที่ลิงก์ไว้ในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง อย่าลืมไปดูกัน วันนี้เราพูดถึงการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach ในปี 1922
มันเป็นหนึ่งในการทดลองที่มีชื่อเสียงที่สุดในประวัติศาสตร์ทฤษฎีควอนตัม เพราะมันแสดงให้เห็นได้ชัดเจนมากว่าสปินควอนตัม
ทำงานอย่างไร แต่นั่นไม่ใช่สิ่งที่ Stern หรือ Gerlach ตั้งใจจะแสดง การทดลองนี้ออกแบบมาเพื่อทดสอบโมเดลควอนตัมใหม่
ของอะตอมที่เรียกว่าโมเดล Bohr ซึ่งตั้งชื่อตาม Niels Bohr ที่เสนอมันในปี 1913 ในโมเดลนี้ อิเล็กตรอนโคจร
รอบนิวเคลียสในวงโคจรที่แยกจากกัน และสามารถเปลี่ยนระหว่างวงโคจรเหล่านั้นได้โดยการดูดซับหรือปล่อย
โฟตอน แต่ละวงโคจรมีโมเมนตัมเชิงมุมที่ถูก quantize ซึ่งเป็นจำนวนเต็มคูณของค่าคงที่พื้นฐานขนาดเล็ก
ที่เรียกว่า h ในยุค 1910 และต้นยุค 20 กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมยังใหม่มาก ใหม่จนกระทั่ง
ยังไม่ได้เรียกว่ากลศาสตร์ควอนตัมด้วยซ้ำ ดังนั้นไม่ใช่ทุกคนที่เชื่อในโมเดล Bohr นักฟิสิกส์
ชื่อ Otto Stern เกลียดมันมาก เขาเรียกโมเดลนี้ว่าไร้สาระ และยังขู่ว่าจะเลิกเรียนฟิสิกส์ถ้า Bohr ถูก
พิสูจน์ว่าถูก Stern ตั้งใจพิสูจน์ให้โมเดลผิดมากจนคิดวิธีทดสอบที่ชาญฉลาด และ
ชักชวน Walther Gerlach มาช่วยออกแบบและทำการทดลอง ปรากฏว่าเขาไม่ได้พิสูจน์ว่า Bohr ผิด เขา
พิสูจน์ว่าตัวเองผิดต่างหาก การทดลองของพวกเขาเรียบง่ายมากและผลลัพธ์ก็ชัดเจนจนเกือบจะยุติ
การถกเถียง กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมครองระดับอะตอม ตอนนั้นพวกเขายังไม่ทราบ
แต่การทดลองของ Stern และ Gerlach ยังพบหลักฐานที่ชัดเจนสำหรับสปินเนื้อแท้ของอิเล็กตรอน ซึ่งเป็น
คุณสมบัติพื้นฐานใหม่ของธรรมชาติที่จำเป็นต่อการอธิบายแม่เหล็ก สภาพนำยิ่งยวด และเคมีส่วนใหญ่
วันนี้เราจะมาดูว่าการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach ทำงานอย่างไร สิ่งที่เราคาดว่าจะเห็นตามฟิสิกส์คลาสสิก
และสิ่งที่ Stern กับ Gerlach ค้นพบจริงๆ แล้วฉันจะแสดงให้เห็นว่าคุณสามารถทำการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach
แบบของตัวเองได้ด้วย Qiskit และคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม IBM ไอเดียพื้นฐานของการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach
คือการหาวิธีพิจารณาว่าโมเมนตัมเชิงมุมของอิเล็กตรอนในอะตอมถูก quantize ตาม
ที่ Bohr ทำนายไว้หรือไม่ ตามที่ Stern คาดว่าไม่ พวกเขาใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าโมเมนตัมเชิงมุมของอิเล็กตรอนจะทำให้มี
สนามแม่เหล็กเล็กๆ รอบแต่ละอะตอม คิดว่ามันเหมือนแม่เหล็กแท่งจิ๋วๆ
การทดลองมีลักษณะแบบนี้ มีเตาอบเต็มไปด้วยอะตอมเงิน
และมีสนามแม่เหล็กที่มีขั้วเหนือและขั้วใต้
ตรงนี้ สนามแรงกว่าใกล้ด้านบนและอ่อนกว่าใกล้ด้านล่าง ดังนั้นมันสร้างความชันชี้ขึ้น
และสุดท้ายมีหน้าจอ ในการทดลอง เตาอบให้ความร้อนอะตอมเงินจนระเหยและ
พวกมันบินออกมาจากเตาโดยมีทิศทางของแม่เหล็กแท่งเล็กๆ ของแต่ละอะตอมแบบสุ่มโดยสมบูรณ์ จากนั้นอะตอม
ผ่านสนามแม่เหล็ก อะตอมจะถูกผลักขึ้นหรือลงด้วยแรงที่ขึ้นอยู่กับทิศทางของ
ขั้วเหนือของแต่ละอะตอมเทียบกับความชันของสนาม แล้วอะตอมก็ชนหน้าจอ Stern กับ Gerlach ดูได้
ว่าอะตอมชนหน้าจอที่ไหนเพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับโมเมนตัมเชิงมุมของอิเล็กตรอน Stern คาดว่าอะตอม
ในการทดลองจะประพฤติตัวตามที่ฉันเล่ามาตลอด เหมือนแม่เหล็กแท่งจิ๋วที่เชื่อฟัง
กฎฟิสิกส์คลาสสิก ตามหลักคลาสสิก แม่เหล็กอะตอมจิ๋วพวกนี้สามารถชี้ไปในทิศทางสุ่มใดก็ได้ ดังนั้นเมื่อ
เดินทางผ่านสนามแม่เหล็ก พวกมันอาจได้รับแรงที่ผลักขึ้นหรือลงในช่วงต่างๆ ขึ้นอยู่กับทิศทางเหล่านั้น แม่เหล็กที่
ชี้ในทิศเดียวกับความชันจะได้รับแรงขึ้นมาก ในทิศตรงข้ามก็จะ
ได้รับแรงลงมาก และถ้าอยู่ตรงกลางก็จะเป็นแรงที่อ่อนกว่า ถ้าอะตอมชี้
ตั้งฉากกับความชัน มันจะไม่รับแรงเลยและเคลื่อนที่ตรงไป เพราะ
ช่วงของแรงที่เป็นไปได้ อะตอมทั้งหมดควรชนหน้าจอที่จุดต่างๆ ตามแนวตั้ง รูปแบบที่จะเกิดขึ้น
บนหน้าจอน่าจะเป็นแบบนี้ แต่นั่นไม่ใช่สิ่งที่ Stern กับ
Gerlach เห็น แต่กลับเห็นกลุ่มอะตอมแยกกันสองกลุ่มบนหน้าจอ โดยไม่มีอะตอมอยู่ตรง
กลางเลย ตอนนั้นพวกเขาไม่มีทฤษฎีที่ถูกต้องในการอธิบายสิ่งนี้ แต่ตอนนี้เรารู้แล้วว่าเห็นแบบนี้เพราะ
อิเล็กตรอนทุกตัวมีโมเมนตัมเชิงมุมเนื้อแท้ในรูปของสปิน ซึ่งสามารถมีค่าได้เพียงหนึ่ง
ในสองค่าเท่านั้น ในภาพแม่เหล็กแท่งของเรา หมายความว่ามีทิศทางที่อนุญาตได้แค่สองทิศทางสำหรับแม่เหล็กอะตอม เรียก
สองทิศทางนี้ว่าสปินขึ้นและสปินลง qubit ในคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
คล้ายกับระบบสปินแบบนี้ และคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมบางตัวใช้ qubit ที่ทำจากสปินของอิเล็กตรอนจริงๆ
ดังนั้นเราสามารถทำการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach ของตัวเองได้ด้วย Qiskit และ qubit ใน IBM quantum computer มา
กำหนดให้สถานะสปินขึ้นของอิเล็กตรอนเป็นสถานะศูนย์ของ qubit และสถานะสปินลงเป็นสถานะหนึ่ง
บน qubit เมื่ออนุภาคเงินออกมาจากเตา พวกมันมีโมเมนตัมแม่เหล็กที่หันไปทิศสุ่ม เรา
สามารถจำลองการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach โดยสร้าง quantum circuit ง่ายๆ ด้วย qubit เดียวที่เริ่มในสถานะศูนย์
นี่เรียกว่าไดอะแกรม circuit โดยสายบนสุดคือ qubit และการดำเนินการที่ใช้กับ qubit
จะแสดงเป็นกล่องบนสาย กล่อง RX และ RZ คือ quantum gate ที่
หมุนทิศทางแม่เหล็กของอะตอมได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ เราสามารถเลือกค่า Theta และ f แบบสุ่มเพื่อหมุน
qubit แบบสุ่ม วิธีนี้จำลองเตาที่ยิงอะตอมออกมาพร้อมทิศทางสปินแบบสุ่ม กล่องสีเทาคือ
การวัด มันบอกเราว่า qubit อยู่ในสถานะศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง และส่งการวัดนั้นไปยัง classical bit
เส้นคู่ที่ระบุว่า C ส่วนนี้เทียบเท่ากับการวัดว่าอะตอมอยู่ในสปินขึ้นหรือสปินลงโดยดูที่
จุดที่มันชนบนหน้าจอ เราสามารถใช้ Qiskit primitive ที่เรียกว่า sampler เพื่อรันการทดลองหลายครั้ง แต่ละครั้งด้วย
ค่าสุ่มต่างกันสำหรับ Theta และ f หลังจาก 100 ตัวอย่าง เราได้ histogram การวัดที่มีลักษณะแบบนี้ ประมาณ
50% ของเวลาที่ qubit ถูกวัดว่าเป็นศูนย์ และ 50% ของเวลาอยู่ในสถานะหนึ่ง นี่คือผลลัพธ์เดียวกันกับที่ Stern
กับ Gerlach เห็น มันเป็นสปินขึ้นหรือสปินลงเสมอ ไม่มีตรงกลางเลย ตอนนี้คุณอาจคิดว่า
แน่นอนเราได้ผลลัพธ์แยกสองค่า เราทำการทดลองบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมดิจิทัลที่คืนค่าแค่
ศูนย์หรือหนึ่งเสมออยู่แล้ว และนั่นก็เป็นความจริง แต่อย่าลืมว่าเหตุผลทั้งหมดที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมคืนค่าแบบไบนารีและ
เหตุผลที่ Quantum Computing ทำงานได้เลยก็เป็นเพราะการ quantize สปินที่ Stern กับ Gerlach ค้นพบครั้งแรกนี่แหละ
qubit ใน IBM quantum computer ไม่ได้ใช้สปิน แต่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอื่นๆ หลายตัวใช้ ดังนั้นการทำ
การทดลอง Stern-Gerlach บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมทำให้เราค้นพบการ quantize สปินใหม่จริงๆ
ตั้งแต่ปี 1922 มีการต่อยอดการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach ดั้งเดิมมากมาย การต่อยอดเหล่านี้เกี่ยวข้องกับ
การส่งลำอะตอมเดียวกันผ่านเครื่องมือ Stern-Gerlach หลายตัวเพื่อดูว่าสปินประพฤติอย่างไรในสถานการณ์ต่างๆ
นี่เป็นอีกอันหนึ่ง มาส่งอะตอมผ่านเครื่องมือหนึ่งเพื่อแยกลำออกเป็นสองส่วนที่สอดคล้องกับ
ลำสปินขึ้นและลำสปินลง แล้วส่งแต่ละลำผ่านเครื่องมือแยกของตัวเอง
ด้วย Qiskit quantum circuit ที่สอดคล้องกับการทดลองนี้คล้ายกับอันที่แล้วแต่มีสอง
การวัดแทนที่จะเป็นหนึ่ง ตรงนี้เราแทนที่การหมุนสุ่มที่จำลองเตาด้วย
gate ที่เรียกว่า Hadamard เพราะการใช้ Hadamard จะให้ความน่าจะเป็นของการวัดเหมือนกับเตา
แต่ใช้งานง่ายกว่ามาก ดังนั้นเราวัดครั้งแรก แล้วก็ครั้งที่สอง และ
histogram การวัดที่ได้มีลักษณะแบบนี้ โดย bit string บนแกน X สอดคล้องกับ
ผลลัพธ์ของการวัดสองครั้ง ถ้า qubit ถูกวัดว่าศูนย์ทั้งสองครั้งก็สอดคล้องกับ bit string 0 0 หรือถ้า
ถูกวัดครั้งแรกเป็นศูนย์แล้วหนึ่งก็สอดคล้องกับ 1 0 เป็นต้น ดูเหมือนว่าถ้าถูกวัดเป็นสปินขึ้นใน
การทดลองแรกก็จะเป็นสปินขึ้นในการทดลองที่สองด้วย เช่นเดียวกับอะตอมสปินลง นั่นหมายความว่าในการทดลองแรก
เรามีโอกาสเท่ากันในการวัดขึ้นหรือลง แต่ถึงการทดลองที่สองผลลัพธ์ถูกกำหนดไว้แล้ว ดังนั้น
หน้าจอสองจอที่ปลายเครื่องมือ Stern-Gerlach ตัวที่สอง แต่ละจอจะมีจุดเดียว หน้าจอหนึ่งจะมี
อะตอมสปินขึ้นทั้งหมดและอีกจอหนึ่งมีอะตอมสปินลงทั้งหมด สำหรับการทดลองต่อไป
มาเริ่มกับลำอะตอมสปินขึ้นล้วนๆ ในการทดลอง Stern-Gerlach จริงๆ คุณทำได้โดยส่ง
ผ่านเครื่องมือ Stern-Gerlach และบังลำที่เบี่ยงลงไว้ ดังนั้นอะตอมทั้งหมดที่เบี่ยงขึ้นล้วน
เป็นสปินขึ้น ตอนนี้มาส่งลำนี้ผ่านเครื่องมือ Stern-Gerlach อีกตัว แต่คราวนี้มาหมุนแม่เหล็ก 90° เพื่อให้
ความชันของสนามเบี่ยงอะตอมที่เดินทางแบบนี้ไปทางซ้ายหรือขวาแทน เราจะ
เห็นจุดเดียวหรือสองจุดหรืออะไรต่างไปจากนั้น สำหรับการทดลองนี้
เราจะรัน circuit นี้บน Qiskit เราจะเริ่มในสถานะศูนย์ เนื่องจากอะตอมในการทดลองนี้ล้วน
เป็นสปินขึ้น จากนั้น Hadamard gate นี้สลับพิกัด x และ z เพื่อให้มีผลเหมือนกับการหมุน
เครื่องมือ Stern-Gerlach ตอนนี้เราวัดการฉายของสปินทางซ้ายหรือขวาแทนที่จะขึ้นหรือลง ตรงนี้เราได้
histogram การวัดที่มีลักษณะแบบนี้ ดังนั้นเราเห็นว่าสปินตามแกน X ก็รับค่าได้แค่สองค่า
ซึ่งเราเรียกว่าสปินซ้ายและสปินขวา การทดลองนี้แสดงว่าถ้าวัดการฉาย X ของสปิน
ที่ก่อนหน้านี้วัดว่าเป็นสปินขึ้นตาม Z มันจะเป็นสปินซ้ายหรือขวาด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากัน มาเปรียบเทียบ
กับความคาดหวังคลาสสิกอีกครั้งเพื่อเน้นความแตกต่างให้ชัดขึ้น จำไว้ว่าตามหลักคลาสสิก
ถ้าแม่เหล็กแท่งอะตอมจิ๋วชี้ตั้งฉากกับความชันของสนามแม่เหล็กของเครื่องมือ
แรงบนอะตอมนั้นควรเป็นศูนย์ มันไม่ควรเบี่ยงขึ้นหรือลง กรณีนั้นเราจะเห็นแค่จุดเดียวตรง
กลางหน้าจอ แต่เรากลับเห็นสองจุด ดังนั้นครึ่งหนึ่งของอะตอมมีสปินซ้ายและอีกครึ่งมีสปินขวา แม้
ว่าก่อนหน้านี้วัดว่าขึ้น ดังนั้นจากมุมมองกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม แม้อาจจะอยากเปรียบ
สปินขึ้นกับเวกเตอร์ที่ชี้ขึ้นและสปินลงกับอันที่ชี้ลง แต่มันไม่ง่ายแบบนั้น อย่างที่เราเห็น
จากการทดลองสุดท้าย เพื่อเข้าใจจริงๆ ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น เราต้องลงลึกในหัวข้อ
quantum superposition และการวัด ซึ่งจะเป็นวิดีโอสำหรับวันอื่น เช่นเดียวกับที่เรายังมีคำถามเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมทำงานอย่างไร Stern และ Gerlach ก็มีเช่นกัน การทดลองของพวกเขาไม่ได้อธิบาย
ทุกอย่าง แต่มันช่วยสร้างรากฐานให้กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมเป็นสิ่งจำเป็นต่อการเข้าใจธรรมชาติได้มาก
มันเป็นหนึ่งในการทดลองพื้นฐานที่สำคัญที่สุดในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมที่ทั้งพิสูจน์การ quantize ของ
โมเมนตัมและให้หลักฐานสำหรับคุณสมบัติพื้นฐานใหม่ของธรรมชาติที่เรียกว่าสปิน เพื่อจะเข้าใจ
กฎของโลกควอนตัมได้จริงๆ นักฟิสิกส์อย่าง Stern และ Gerlach ต้องลงมือจริง ออกแบบ
การทดลอง ทำนายผล และบางครั้งก็ผิดพลาด ไม่มีอะไรทดแทนการลองทำด้วยตัวเองได้จริงๆ
ดังนั้นถ้าอยากลองทำการทดลองควอนตัมจริงๆ ไปที่โมดูล Stern-Gerlach
ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบาย ขอบคุณที่รับชม แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า